-How are you?
-Still alive.
And thriving. Thriving.
-Thriving. You know.
-54! You just turned --
You had your birthday yesterday!
-Thanks for that. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I would have -- You don't
want to say someone's age,
but you actually had
a Studio 54-themed party.
-I did, last night.
I did 54, yeah.
-And this is --
As you would assume,
Alan Cumming has a very
laid-back birthday party,
just like any of us...
with what looks like
a real fire hazard of a cake.
-That was terrifying.
-That really was.
I'm feinting comfort there,
but I was actually
a little scared.
This was in this really great
place actually.
It's a water tower, a bar
in Williamsburg
in this hotel called
the Williamsburg Hotel.
It's an old water tower,
-And it's big enough
for you to be -- Oh. Yeah.
-This is inside a water tower.
-That's fantastic.
-There's no water anymore,
obviously.
-Well, obviously. You couldn't
have a cake like that
in a water tower with water.
And then you ended up at --
You have a bar.
At my bar. Club Cumming.
-Club Cumming.
-There's the after party.
-There you go.
And you won -- Club Cumming is
an award-winning establishment.
-It just won -- [ Laughs ]
It won the Best Bar at the Glam
Awards a couple of weeks ago,
which is so exciting.
Did I not tell you?
-That's really exciting!
At the end of the night
like that,
do you end up behind the bar?
Are you serving people drinks?
-Yes.
I usually go -- I usually go --
Like, it's quite a fun place
to be behind the bar
seeing to all the bar people.
And also it keeps you kind of
a wee distance from everybody.
And you can fill
your own drinks.
But I know -- And I enjoy --
Like, I take people's orders,
and I do, you know --
I love doing the thing,
the little computer --
ding, ding, ding.
I'm very -- I actually use
my well-known-ness
to cover up my bad
bartending skills.
People will say stuff like, "Oh,
can I have a tequila sunrise?"
And I go,
"How about a tequila soda?"
"Can I have an old-fashioned?"
I'm like,
"How about a vodka soda?
What would that be like?"
I just can't -- I don't pretend
that I'm -- I don't want to.
And also it's better
to have a soda drink.
You don't want any of those
sugary, yucky things.
-No, and I will say,
no matter how much
you want an old-fashioned,
you don't want one
made by somebody
who doesn't know how to do it.
-Mine would be terrible.
I once gave someone --
Instead of a Jack and Coke,
because the gun thing --
It's got "C."
I maybe had been
drinking myself,
because the cranberry
is cranberry-colored.
But the Coke one isn't.
It's just white.
I got confused with the two C's,
so I gave them
a Jack and cranberry.
-Yeah. And that --
I think when you get
a Jack and Coke wrong,
that has really told you
what kind of bartender
you're dealing with.
-You'd better be owning the bar.
-'Cause they say
that's a slam dunk.
That's day one
of bartender school.
-Exactly, yeah.
-You have --
Your new show coming up,
going to previews, "Daddy."
-Yes.
-Very exciting any time
you start a new show.
I'm assuming there are
a degree of nerves.
-Yes.
-You also -- This is a show
with a great deal of nudity.
-There is a lot of nudity
of myself
and that young gentleman there,
Ronald Peet.
We are naked.
It's an incredible play.
It's this new, young
African-American writer
called Jeremy O. Harris, who
wrote a play called "Slave Play"
that was on a theater workshop.
And this is another kind of
expedition of, you know,
race and queerness and
intergenerational things.
[ Laughs ] And so I --
And there's a swimming pool
on stage.
I'm, like, an arts collector
in Los Angeles.
And I'm very rich.
And I have a big, swanky house.
So, there's a pool, and a lot of
the time I am naked in the pool.
-I feel bad because
of the way I asked that.
Obviously, this is
an intelligently written play
that deals with heavy themes.
And I was like, "So, uh, yeah.
So I heard you're naked."
-[ Laughs ]
-So I apologize.
Particularly
to the writer of this work
that that's where I went
immediately.
-But the thing I think about
nudity is actually sustained --
Like, I think
if you're going to do it,
especially with this play
which is about really important
discussions about things that
I think should be talked about
and we're not talking about them
in this country enough,
to do with race and things.
But, you know, the nakedness,
I think you can't be coy.
You can't be coy
about things like that.
So my thing is,
let's just do it.
And, like, you know, hopefully
after a couple of minutes,
people will stop
checking you out.
And I think the thing is,
if you're coy
and sort of do a little towel,
it makes people more like,
"Oh, I saw a flash!"
But you're going to get
more than a flash.
All the way through.
At one point, I have to run --
We're in the pool.
And I have to lift him.
We're naked in the pool.
And I have to lift him up.
And he is, like, a big boy.
And lift him up and go
over the steps, like that.
And carry him and then sit down
and then spank him with a shoe.